there are certain people who try and
reconciliate and say that the six days
mentioned in the Bible it actually
refers to epochs like the Quran long
period not 624 days it's illogical you
read the Bible evening morning it
clearly stes 24 hours it indicates but
even if I use a Concord dis approach no
problem I agree with your illogical
argument yet they will only be able to
solve the first scientific error of six
days creation and second that first day
light and third the Earth the remaining
four yet they cannot
solve
some further say that if it's a 24
period why can't the vegetable survive
for 24 day without
sunlight I say fine if you say that the
vegetables were created before the sun
and can survive for 124 a day I have got
no objection but you can't say the days
mention are 24 hours as well as EPO you
can't have the Kake and eat it both if
you say it is long period you solve
Point number one and three the remaining
four are yet there if you say the days
are 24 days you solve only Point number
five the remaining five are yet there it
becomes unscientific I live it to Dr
William Campbell whether he wants to say
it is long period and say that there are
only four scientific errors or say it is
a 24 days and say there only five
scientific errors in the creation of the
universe regarding the concept of
Earth there are various scientists who
have described how will the world end
hypothesis some may be right some may be
wrong but either the world will perish
or the world will live forever both
cannot take place simultaneously it's
unscientific but this is exactly what
the Bible says it's mentioned in the
Bible in the book of Hebrews chapter
number one verse number 10 11 and in the
Book of Psalms chapter number 102 verse
number 25 and 26 that almighty God
created the heavens and the Earth and
they will
perish exactly opposite is mentioned in
the book of easis chapter number one
verse number four and the Book of Psalms
chapter number 78 verse number 69 that
the Earth will abide
forever I leave it to Dr William
Campbell to choose which of the two
verses unscientific the first pair or
the second pair one has to be
unscientific both cannot take place the
cannot abide forever as well as perish
it's
unscientific regarding the heavens the
Bible says in Job 26:1 that the pillars
of the heaven will tremble Quran says in
Sur lukman 31: number 10 that the
heavens are without any pillars don't
you see it don't you see the heavens are
without any pillars Bible says Heaven
has got pillars not only do the heavens
have got pillars Bible says in the first
book of Samuel chapter number 2 verse
number 8 as well as the Book of Job
chapter number 9 verse number 6 and the
Book of Psalms chapter number 75: number
3 that even the Earth have got
pillars in the field of diet and
nutrition let's analyze what does the
Bible say the Bible says in the Book of
Genesis chapter number one verse number
that God has given you all the herbs
bearing seeds
the trees bearing fruits those that bear
seed as meat for you New International
Version says the seed bearing plant and
the trees bearing fruits bearing seeds
are food for you all of them
today even a lay man knows that there
are several poisonous plants like wild
berries strine datura plants containing
alkaloid oanda bakid
that which if you ingest if you eat
there are high possibilities you may
die how come the creator of the universe
and human beings doesn't know that if
you have these plants you will die I
hope Dr William Campbell doesn't give
this vegetarian diet to his
patients the Bible has a scientific test
how to identify a True Believer it's
mentioned in the gospel of Mark chapter
number 16 verse number 17 and 18
it says that there will be signs for
True Believers and among the
signs in my name they shall cast out
Devils they shall speak foreign tongues
new tongues they shall take up serpents
and if they drink deadly poison they
shall not be harmed and when they Place
their hand over the sick they shall be
cured this is a scientific test in
scientific terminology it's known as the
confirmatory test
for a true Christian believer in the
past 10 years of my life I have
personally interacted with thousands of
Christians including missionary I have
not come across a single Christian who
has passed this confirmat test of the
Bible I have not come across a single
Christian who took poison I not come
across any who took poison and who has
not
died and in scientific terminology this
is also called as a falsification test
that means if a false person tries and
does this test takes poison he will
die and a false person will not dare
attemp this test if you are not a true
Christian believer you will not dare
attempt this test because if you try and
attempt the falsification test you will
fail so a person who is not a true
Christian believer will never attempt
this test I have read the book
the Quran the Bible in the light of
History and Science written by Dr
William Campbell and I
assume that he is a true Christian
believer and at least I would like him
to confirm to me about the falsification
Test please be rest assured please be
rest assured I will not ask Dr William
Campbell to have deadly poison because I
don't want to geze the
debate what I'll do I will only ask him
to speak in foreign tongues in new
languages and as many of you may be
aware that India is a land which has
more than thousand languages and
dialects only thing I request him is to
say these three
words 100 rupees in the 17 official
languages
there are only 17 official languages in
India and to make it easier for Dr
William
Campbell I've got a 100 rupee
note and this has all the 17 languages
mentioned here besides English and Hindi
I will help him I'll give him a
beginning in
Hindi the remaining 15 languages are
here I request him to read I know the
test says they will speak for foreign
languages on their own without the help
of reading but I want to make the test
easier I want to see someone passing the
test I have not seen anyone so if you
can't say it on his own or from his
memory at least read it I don't mind
I'll will accept it and I request the
chair person to give it Dr William
Campbell he has his rebuttle 15
languages three words
only what does the Bible say
regarding hydrology Bible says in
Genesis chapter number 9 verse number
13- 17 that after God at the time of
Noah
submerged the World by flood and after
the flood subsided he said I put up a
rainbow in the sky as a promise to the
humankind never to submerge the world
again by
water to the unscientific person it may
be quite good oh rainbow is a sign of
Mighty God never to submerge the World
by flood again but today we know very
well that rainbow is due to the
refraction of sunlight with rain orist
surely there may have been thousands of
rainbows before the time of Noah peace
be upon him to say it was not there
before Noah's time you have to assume
that the law of refraction did not exist
which is
unscientific in the field of
medicine the Bible says in the Book of
Leviticus chapter number 14 verse number
49 to 53 it gives a Noel way for
disinfecting a house from plague of
leprosy disinfecting a house from plague
of leprosy it says that take two birds
kill one bird take wood Scarlet hop and
the other living bird dip it in water
and under running water later on
Sprinkle the house seven times with it
sprinkle the house with blood to
disinfect against plague of
leprosy we know blood is a good media of
germ bacteria as well as toxin I hope Dr
William Campbell doesn't use this method
of disinfecting the OT the operation
theater it's mentioned in the Book of
Leviticus chapter number 12 verse number
1 to
5 and we know medically that after a
mother gives birth to a
child the postpartum period it is
unhygienic to say it's unclean
religiously I've got no objection but
Leviticus number 12 verse number 1 to5
says that after a woman gives birth to a
male child she will be unclean for 7even
days and the period of uncleanness will
continue for 33 days more if she gives
birth to a female child she'll be
unclean for two weeks and the period of
uncleanness will continue for 660 days
in short if a woman gives birth to a
male child a son she is unclean for 40
days if she gives birth to a female male
child or daughter she's unlean for 80
days I would like Dr William Campbell to
explain to me scientifically how come a
woman remain unclean for double the
period if she gives birth to a female
child as compared to a male
child the Bible also has a very good
test for adultery how to come to know a
woman has committed adulter in Book of
Numbers Chapter number 5 verse number 11
to 31 I'll just say in brief it says
that the priest should take holy water
in a vessel take dust from the floor and
put it into the
vessel and that's the bit of
water and after cursing it give it to
the
woman and if the woman has committed
adultery after she drinks it the curse
will enter her body the stomach will
swell the thigh will rot and she shall
be cursed by the people if the woman has
not committed adultery she will remain
clean and she will bear the seed a novel
method of identifying whether a woman
has committed adultery or not you know
today in the world there are thousands
of cases pending in different parts of
the world in different courts of law
only on the assumption that someone has
alleged that the woman has committed
adultery I had
read in the newspapers and I came to
know from the media that the president
of this great country Mr Bill Clinton he
was involved in a sex scandal about two
years back
I wonder that why didn't the American
Court use this bitter water test for
adultery he would have gone scotf free
immediately why didn't the Christian
missionaries of this great country
especially those who are in the medical
field like my respected Dr William
Campbell use these better water test to
bail out the president
immediately mathematics is a branch
which is closely associated with science
with which you can solve problems
Etc there are thousands of
contradictions in the Bible hundreds
deal with mathematics I'll just touch on
few of
them it's mentioned in Ezra chapter
number two verse number one and nem
chapter number 7 verse number six the
context that when the people return from
Exile from Babylon when King nebuchad
of Babylon when he released the men from
Israel they came back from captivity and
the list of the people are given the
list is given in Ezra chapter number 2
verse number 2 to 63 and nemia chapter
number 7 verse number 7 up to 65 the
list is given with the names as well as
number of people released in these 60
verses there are no less than 18 times
the name is exactly the same but the
number is different there are no less
than 18
contradictions in less than 60 verses of
these two
chapters this is the list I don't have
time to run through the list there are
no less than 18 different
contradictions in less than 60
verses further it's mentioned in Ezra
chapter number two verse number 64 that
the total congregation if you add up if
you add up it comes to
42,00 360 and if you read in nemia
chapter number
7 verse number 66 there also the total
is the same
42360 but if you add up all these
verses which I had to do my homework
this is a list this is a list of
Ezra this is a list of nemia Ezra
chapter number two nemia chapter number
7 if you add up I had to do my homework
if you add up in Ezra chapter number two
it doesn't come to
42360 it comes to
2988 and if you add up nemia chapter
number 7 even there doesn't come to
42360 it comes to
3189 the author of The the Bible
presumed to be almighty God does not
know simple addition if you give this
problem even to a person who passed
Elementary School he'll be able to get
the right answer if you add up all the
verses it's so easy almighty
God then know adding Noah if we presume
that this is the word of God further if
we read in Ezra chapter number
two verse number 65 it says there were
200 singing men and women nemia CH
number 7: 67 there were 245 singing men
and women were
there 200 or were there 245 singing men
and women context is the same a
mathematical
contradiction it's mentioned in the
second Kings chapter number 24 verse
number 8 that joachin was 18 years old
when he began to Reign Jerusalem and he
reigned for 3 months 2 Chronicles
chapter number 36 verse number 9 says
that joachin was 8 years old when he
began to rain and he rained for 3 months
10 days was joachin 18 years when he
began to rain or was he 8 years old did
he rain for 3 months or did he rain for
3 months 10
days further it's mentioned in the First
Kings chapter number 7 verse number 26
that in Solomon's Temple in his molten
sea he had 2,000
BS in 2 Chronicles chapter number four
verse number five he had 3,000 BS did he
have 2,000 BS or did he have 3,000 BS
that I leave it upon William Campell to
decide which is correct there is a
clear-cut mathematical contradiction
it's mentioned in the First Kings
chapter number 15 verse number 33 that
Basha he died in the 26th year of Reign
of
Assa
and 2 Chronicles chapter number 16 verse
number one says that Basha invaded Judah
in the 36th year of the reign of Assa
how can basa invade 10 years after his
death it's
unscientific to make it easier for Dr
William Campbell to
answer to the points I've raised I'll
just mention it in brief the points that
I mentioned the first point was the
creation of the earth and the heaven the
universe was in 624 days
light was there before the source of
light Point number two
three they came into existence before
creation of Earth Point number four
Earth came into existence before Sun
Point number five vegetation came into
existence before sunlight Point number
six light of the moon is its own
light Point number
seven the
Earth will it perish or will it abide
forever Point number
eight the Earth has got pillars Point
number nine the heavens have got pillars
Point number 10 God said you can have
all plants and all vegetation including
the poisonous plants Point number 11 the
scientific test the falsification test
of Mark chapter number 16 verse number
17 and 18 point number 12 a woman
remains unclean for double the period if
she give birth to a daughter as compared
to a son
Point number
13 using blood to disinfect the house
against plague of
leprosy Point number
14 how do you find out the bit of water
test for
adultery Point number 15 18 different
contradictions in less than 60 verses of
isra chapter 2 and N chapter number
seven I didn't count them as 18
different I've counted them only as
one point number six
16 the total is different in both the
chapters Point number 17 are there 200
singing men and women or are there 245
singing men and
women Point number
18 was join 18 years old or was he 8
years old when he began to rain Point
number
19 did he rain for 3 months or 3 months
10 days Point number
20 did Solomon had 3,000 BS or 2,000
BS Point number 21
one
is that Basha how could he invade Judah
10 years after his death Point number
22 is almighty God he said I put up a
rainbow in the sky as a promise to the
human kind never to submerge the world
again by
water I have listed only 22 out of the
hundreds available
unscientific points in the Bible
scientific errors and I request Dr
William C B to answer them and
irrespective whether uses the Concord
approach or the conflict approach as
long as he's logical he will never be
able to prove scientifically all these
22 aspects I have told him we
agree in Jesus Christ peace be upon him
to him was revealed the inil this is not
the inil it may contain part of God but
the other unscientific portion is not
the word of God I would like to end my
talk by giving the quotation of the
Glorious Quran from Surah Bak chapter
which
says V to those who write the book with
their own hands and then say this is
from Allah to traffic with it for a
miserable price vote to those for what
they write vote to those for what they
earn
[Applause]
I would request our audience to bear
bear with us and maintain a due decorum
for the continuation of the
dialogue now I call upon Dr William
Campbell to present his response to Dr
Zakir Nik
[Applause]
well Dr Nike has brought up some real
problems and there are some these
problems that he has said and I don't
deny them and I don't have good answers
for them but I will tell
[Applause]
about we're going to make a mathematical
study of prophecies it's called the
theory of
probabilities estimate and will estimate
the possibility that these prophecies
could be fulfilled by
chance I know call upon Dr Zakir Nik to
present his response to Dr William
Campbell Dr William Campbell only
touched on two out of the 22 points I
made only two you can only solve two
problems the sixth day creation problem
and first day light came and Third Day
Earth but the remaining more problems
yet is there so Dr William Campbell
chose to say days a long period and out
of six he solved two scientific errors
the remaining four of the creation of
the universe he does agree to it that's
good the King James version as well as
the New International Version which Dr
William Campbell refers to drink deadly
poison not eat drink
[Applause]
Dr William Campell doesn't know there
are Indians out here surely many know
Gujarati marati even I know if I ask
you Dr William Campbell did not reply to
my 20 points and he started speaking
about prophecy what has prophecy to do
with science in the Bible if prophecy is
the
test but even if there's one unfulfilled
prophecy the whole Bible is disproof the
word of God I can give you a list of
unfulfilled prophecy according to your
theory of theory of probability Bible is
not the word of
God irrespective whether you use the
conflict approach or the concordance
approach if you're logical you will not
be able to take out a single verse of
the Quran which is contradicting neither
a single verse which is against
established science
if Dr William Campbell cannot understand
the Quran that does not mean Quran is
wrong Bible says in Job chapter number
10 verse number n and 10 that we have
made the human being from clay like P do
milk and curdled cheese P do milk and C
cheese is exact plagiarization from
hypocrates yes I'd like to pose this
question or
other uh this test to Dr William
Campbell why don't you attempt the
falsification test of the Bible given in
The Book of
Mark
16: 17 and
18 and prove to the audience here right
now that you are a true Christian
believer um my question is to Dr zacher
Nik the Christians explain the concept
of Trinity scientifically by giving the
example of water which can be in three
states solid liquid and gas in the form
of ice water and Vapor
similarly one God is a Triune god father
Son and Holy Ghost is this explanation
scientifically
correct the word Trinity is not there in
the Bible but it is there in the Quran
Dr zaker you said there isn't any
mistake in Quran I see more than 20
mistake in Arabic grammar and I will
tell you some of them
he
said which is
right
or number one number two brother brother
one question at a time yeah but at the
same thing he said in
63 mistake
in can you explain
that and the book is referring to ABD
Abdul Fadi correct is the Quran
infallible I can see some things yeah
alhamdulillah my side is
[Applause]
good Dr Campbell since you are a medical
doctor could you please explain
scientifically the various medical
aspects that in the Bible regarding
because you didn't answer them in your
rebuttal for example blood used as a
disinfectant bitter water test for
adultery and most importantly that the
woman is unclean for double the period
when she gives birth to a daughter then
as compared to a
son okay Dr Campbell if you cannot
answer the contradictions in Genesis
regarding the creation don't you think
that the that proves that the Bible is
unscientific and therefore not from God
I admit that I have some problem s with
this the Muslim yashik the Quran is far
superior to your yashik the sence
therefore you should believe in Quran
Which is far
superior Dr Campbell agreed to Dr Nike
that the errors he showed are not wrong
and that he can't answer them so does
this mean that Dr Campbell agrees that
the Bible has errors so it's not the
word of God there are things in the
Bible that I can't explain that I don't
have an answer for now how can the son
be 2 years older than the
father believe me even even in Hollywood
film you will not be able to produce it
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my Creator oh Allah fulfill our AIMS
in life Allah forgive our s yeah Allah
oh Allah the most gracious